hey guys this Max right over here I have
the new narwhal fro X Ultra now we have
covered the Narwhal Frio on our Channel
and I actually personally purchased one
myself and I use it daily at my house
because it is amazing now they have the
new Foo X Ultra and it has a ton of
improvements including some that nobody
else on the market has now you guys see
the outside looks similar what I love
about it is that it looks classy there's
not a bunch of different boxes is it's
nice and sleek and on the top we have a
nice LCD that you can use if you don't
want to use your phone they have a lot
of different options now this thing has
a ton of features I want to start out
with the suction power over here you
guys can see that we have a bunch of
Steel balls and this test right here
shows off it's 88,200 PA suction so even
though these are very heavy it has no
problems sucking all of them up in its
first try and that just shows you how
powerful it is now if we scoot over this
way um I'm going to show you guys the
inside of the tank all of this is
actually hidden inside of the unit and
it actually will take the water it'll
distribute it it will add the detergent
um it will sense um how dirty the water
is to see if it needs to be clean more
I'll show you that in just a second and
of course built inside of the case here
we have our fresh waterer tank and our
dirty water tank that you just pull out
and you can um add some fresh water and
dumping it actually takes me about a
minute when I do that now you can also
put your detergent in here and it will
grab it and mix it with the water and
put it on the brushes now let me pull
this robot out of here and if you take a
look at it it looks similar to the
original one but the cover is a little
bit different the whole thing comes off
and you guys can see that the bag is a
lot different compared to most other
options on on the market same thing if I
go ahead and flip this over these
rollers look the same and they work
amazing but this right here looks a
little bit different than what you're
used to now of course on the inside it
will still go ahead and dry these mops
so clean them up it has heated dry to
make sure that there's no smell or no
issues when you're using it now come
over here let me show you something that
is really cool if you take a look at
this demo this is showing off their new
anti- tank roller now if you see this
roller this is what is in most robot
vacuums you have the two edges that pop
in and you'll get a bunch of hair and
stuff that will get stuck in it but what
narwhal has done with this new uh fro X
Ultra is they designed the single sided
brush and that allows it to brush really
well but at the same time be able to
take any hair and it instantly sucks it
in without it getting stuck now that is
great because it just makes for a lot
less maintenance less times you have to
take it and you know cut the hair
dispose of it and it is actually
certified it is the only Robot vacuum
that actually is certified for 0% uh
tangling on the brush so that is proven
now if we step over here you guys will
see the bag that they have now this is
really cool because even though the
Narwhal doesn't use a station that will
suck dust out of it and any dirt and
empty it um it has this other design
that actually works better now the issue
with the boxes the base stations that
will suck dust out is dust can clog it
can smell after a while but this design
is really nice because it will take all
the dust and it will compress it and
that makes sure that there's no smells
nothing extra to do but it will actually
hold all the dust and dirt for up to 7
weeks without you having to empty it and
when it is time to empty it here's the
actual baggie you can just clip this off
throw it away pop a new one onto here
and then you don't have to deal with
cleaning it out so that is a really nice
upgrade it's also really quiet they have
a quieter mode no clogging no issues to
deal with now if we step over here you
guys will see these brush heads now
these are the same that are on my
original narwhal Foo the foo works well
because if you take a look at the
Triangular pads they're actually
touching right here and that allows it
to get everything instead of having a
gap in between rollers it will actually
touch everything you guys also saw that
it popped out and when it pops out
that's when it's cleaning your floors
and it actually has 12 Newtons of force
to push against your floor to make sure
that it is nice and clean and then if
it's cleaning carpet uh or anything else
rugs it'll actually go back in and then
it won't be getting the weight getting
caught on things and then of course
these actually just pop right off if you
want to swap them or if you don't need
them now here is their little station
that they have set up for dirt scents
now right here we have this little uh
display and let's just put some regular
water through it right there we have a
little bit of soil level probably
because of the chocolate milk and if we
grab this chocolate milk here we go
through we have a high soil level now
why that is important is because when
your robot vacuum is mopping a lot of
Brands it will just go mop once or twice
and that is it but with the Narwhal it
can actually sense the dirt in the
station see how dirty it is and it will
keep going back and mop as many times as
it needs to make sure that your floors
are clean and that just makes sure that
everything is great now another thing
that I want to show you is this station
right over here now the Narwhal Frio
that I have it has liar it does a good
job but it has two lasers where the new
fro X Ultra it actually has three lasers
the two in the front and the one on the
side now nobody else has this and the
reason this is important is when you
have obstacles a lot of vacuums have
obstacle avoidance but what they do is
they stay away from uh obstacle a chair
and they stay quite far away to make
sure it doesn't hit it with the new
triple laser system it can actually
sense how close it is on the side
and that allows it to get really close
to obstacles so it can clean the floor
without um actually bumping into it and
that's just make sure that everything is
nice and clean even if something was
left out now the app is also updated
with extra features for the foo X Ultra
and I love my original narwhal like I
said I use it every day but the new one
is updated and just makes it a lot more
convenient in many areas now if you're
interested in one we're going to have a
link in the description and they
actually have have a pre-order special
price so if you pay 20 bucks you
actually get $300 off which is a big
deal but it also comes with a year of
accessories so the bags the mops
everything you need plus some surprise
gifts will be shipped to you guys so
check out the link down in the video
description this has been Max thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one